- Do y'all do any like family traditions?
Like I know your mom,
like I love your mom.
Every time we tell stories-
- [Kit] Oh my gosh.
- Does she have any fun things?
- So guys, my mom's name is Bug
and Bug is in love with Kelly.
- I love Bug.
- She told me today,
she said wear a lot of
blush and talk slow.
(Kelly laughs)
So, Bug, I'm trying my best.
- Neither one of us-
- [Kit] Neither one of us.
- Talks slow.
(Kelly laughs)
- I have all my mom's decorations.
When I was a little girl in the '70s,
(Kelly vocalizes)
she like hand painted stuff.
It was really big in the '70s.
- What?
- So I have like Christmas
villages and all her old stuff.
Then my brother and I fight
over it and I got everything.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- But, so I've got all that up.
And then I used to do the Christmas card
or the holiday card,
which I don't do anymore,
with pictures of the kids,
'cause they're too old.
- We used to do that, yeah.
- I love a bad card.
I like when you get a wonky photo-
- [Kelly] Like the fun ones.
- Or my mom's, Bug would look gorgeous
and then my brother and I
would be like one eye shut-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Or one time
she cut off my brother's head
and put it on a picture
of me in high school
that she thought I looked really pretty.
So my brother's ear,
this is the '70s,
there was no computers or anything.
- No Photoshop.
His neck was really pointy and weird
and the ear was off and
my brother was like-
(audience laughing)
- [Kelly] This is not a joke.
- Love the Hoovers, yeah.
- This is not a joke.
I've talked about this on the show before.
My mom used to do that, she'd cut us out
and we never went on
vacation 'cause we were poor.
But she'd put us like in
a beautiful destination.
- Yes, yes.
(audience awhs)
- She'd put the pictures if like,
wasn't that exciting?
- [Kit] Yes.
- Like yeah.
- [Kit] I can beat that.
Do you remember the mountains?
- Do you remember the mountains?
(Kelly laughs)
There was a funeral home
in Atlanta, Georgia,
near where I grew up that had beautiful-
What is the segue here?
(audience laughs)
Wait, you're gonna get it.
That had beautiful grounds.
- Oh.
- Like impeccable grounds.
We took our Christmas card here every year
at the funeral home-
- [Kelly] Stop.
- And mom acts, like Bug acts
like it was our backyard.
And there's my brother and I outside.
I can't remember the name of it.
- You took your Christmas family photo
at a funeral place?
- Year after year, Kelly.
We followed it-
- Oh my.
Straight the way through,
until finally my brother and I-
- I love your family.
- Are like, "Mom, this is weird".
And then we leaned in,
we're like saddle up the car, kids.
And I took my kids there.
I'm like, I know where we're going.
Patterson's Funeral home.
That was the name of it.
- Oh my God.
That's hysterical.
So many family traditions
are being started right now.
- [Kit] Started right now.
(Kelly laughs)